Today is the last day that you can pre-order
our brand new Diatom t-shirt at microcosmos.store.
And if you do that right now,
the day that the video comes out.
And I know some of you are watching it
later and I'm sorry for that.
you should be receiving
it in just a few weeks.
We will have it later on for sale,
for the general population.
But for you early watchers you can
pre-order it and get it first.
So if you want to look like the exact
kind of nerd that you are,
head to microcosmos.store.
This doesn't look like much.
If you saw it on the street, you’d think,
"Yeah that's, that's a bit of gravel."
But every day, tiny little things, just like this
are raining down on our planet from space.
Each one is small, about a millimeter across.
So when they land, we barely notice.
But over the course of a year, each individual
piece that makes its way to Earth
adds up to around 30,000 tons.
That’s a lot of tons of stuff that are
so tiny that they escapes our notice.
But of course, here on journey to the microcosmos,
these are exactly the kinds of things
that we like to look at.
These are micrometeorites, just a few of millions
that pass through our atmosphere every single day.
Most don’t survive the journey from space.
They simply vaporize in our atmosphere.
But those that do survive go through quite a transformation
as they soar through our planet’s atmosphere,
melting with the friction of their entrance.
Depending on their speed and rotation and
chemical composition, their shapes warp and
recrystallize in new shapes.
They may become more elongated, or perhaps
develop pointed shapes around their body.
But from a distance, they could be anything.
A piece of sand or a speck of dust… so,
if it seems difficult to find a micrometeorite,
that’s because it is.
James, our master of microscopes, received
these samples from a friend of his, Scott
Peterson, who has been hunting micrometeorites
for some time, examining rooftops and their
relatively undisturbed environments to see
what he can find.
And if you want to see how well you would
do as a micrometeorite hunter, here’s a
little test for your skills.
Let’s say you’re looking at this array
of pearly looking bits and bobs.
Do you think you can find micrometeorites
there?
You can pause, take a moment.
This is the micrometeorite.
Alright so now that you’ve seen one, can you
find them in the next few slides we’ll show you?
Again, just pause if you need
a moment, take a look,
and we will show you the
micrometeorites at the end.
Let’s start with this.
Then this.
And last, this.
So now that you’ve had a moment to look
at them all, let’s go through them to see
how well you did.
First, we have the micrometeorite here, which
looks similar to the other pearly round things,
except that it’s a little  less shiny.
And then here, the micrometeorite was right
in the middle of everything.
While here, it was off in the corner.
And our last one seems practically impossible
to distinguish from everything else.
Sorting out these micrometeorites feels a
bit like trying to navigate the microcosmos.
There’s just so much stuff to sort through,
it requires patience and it requires knowledge.
But at the end, the result is understanding that allows
us to identify and classify our universe so
that we can build some kind of framework to
understand it.
So it is weird and cool that we just walk
around our world surrounded by these little
bits of the cosmos that got past our atmosphere.
Sort of like it’s weird and cool that we
just walk around our world surrounded by
microbes that we never see or think about.
And for us, as people who talk about microbes
a lot, it’s hard to not spend some of this
time imagining what it would be like for our
microbes to make the opposite journey.
To go from our world, past the atmosphere,
and back into whatever is beyond.
Unfortunately, as talented as our master of
microscopes is, he has yet to go into space.
So just know that the footage we’re showing
now are not actually microbes in space.
Think of them more as a vibe, a background
for us to project onto as we consider the possibilities.
Microbes are crafty, hardy creatures.
In the billions of years that they have existed,
they’ve managed to adapt to countless environments
and survived monumental shifts in climate.
But we also live on a planet that has so far
shown itself to be uniquely nurturing.
What about everywhere else?
Now we’re not talking about aliens, though of
course we could.
There is a rover on Mars right now, seeking
out the possibility that life may have existed there.
But we don’t need to consider aliens to
imagine microbes in space.
Because...
there are microbes there.
We brought them there.
Because well, humans have gone to space,
and where we go, microbes go as well.
In our cargo, our food, and of course, our
bodies.
In 2020, researchers studying the International
Space Station found that after two decades
of humans living there, the space station
itself seems to have a microbiome of its own,
made up of 55 microbial genera—an array
of bacteria and fungi and protists and other
creatures that are invisible roommates to
the astronauts.
And if you’re painting an image of superpowered
microbes that have been mutated into something
unrecognizable and dangerous by cosmic rays…fortunately,
NASA looked into it, and they found the microbes
are not dangerous.
Though there were some microbes, particularly
fungi, that have caused some damage to windows
because of their unusual ability to grow on
metal.
And even when humans aren't being sent to
space, our microbial marks can be left on
the things we do send to space,
which does pose some challenges.
For example, the Perseverance rover is looking
for microbes on Mars, but it needs to make
sure that any signs of microbial life it sees
aren’t actually accidental terrestrial hitchhikers.
So NASA had to build the spacecraft while
keeping it as clean as possible, ensuring
that the Mars 2020 Mission was launched with
10 times less bacteria on it than the amount
that live in a teaspoon of seawater.
Because space might not kill those microbes
for us.
The ones that can form spores or cysts can
use those adaptations out in space as well.
So even with the vacuum and the radiation
and the massive shifts in temperatures, some
microbes can survive.
ln 2020, a team of researchers created dried
aggregates of the UV radiation-resistant bacteria
Deinococcus radiodurans and they put them
on panels outside the International Space Station—
a place where not much seems like it should
survive.
But after three years, they found bacteria
in those pellets that survived, buried under
a surface layer that hadn’t survived but
was able to protect those underneath.
There’s something about that—about the
way a mass of bacteria can be dried out and
placed in an environment so far from its origins—that
feels perfect as a meeting of the microcosmos
and the cosmos.
Just as micrometeorites burn through our atmosphere
and blend with our planet, microbes can
find their own way to become a part of the
world outside our planet.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us
And if you've forgotten what we said at the beginning,
yes today is the last day to to pre-order our new Diatom T-shirt
over at microcosmos.store.
Now that the video is over, you can just go do that.
But since you stayed to the end of the video,
we also wanted to let you know
that you can get 10% off our set of 4 plan
objectives if you wanna use the promo code
PLAN10 at checkout.
That deal only runs through March 6th, so
you will want to pick those up soon, if you
want to upgrade your Microcosmos Microscope.
The link for those and our diatom t-shirt
are both in the description below.
Thanks so much to all the people on the screen
right now.
They are our patrons on Patreon.
They are the reason that we're able to make
Journey to the Microcosmos and explore topics
as diverse as bacteria on the outside of space
stations and micro meteorites that are all
around us all the time that we never even
notice.
So if you like what we do here, these are
some of the people to thank.
And if you'd like to become one of them, you
can go to Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro.
If you'd like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you'd like to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.